could Paramount really sell the Star
Trek franchise to a competitor it might
not be as ridiculous as it sounds and it
might actually already be happening
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
there's a few reasons why I'm doing this
video one of them being the Star Trek is
my second favorite franchise of all
sci-fi into what my first one is
and I I've always been a Trekkie I have
not been the massive fan of new Trek I
actually I adore lower decks you know I
do the card series one started great let
us down Picard Series 2 started really
great let us down picassius 3 apparently
is supposed to be getting back to its
roots are supposed to be amazing but I
won't hold my breath
strange new worlds actually if you break
down the show it's not great but the
characters are so brilliant you just
don't care
so that's basically my summary of
current Star Trek I'm not Alex
kurtzman's biggest fan and if you are a
regular sidetracker you know I did a
video a little while ago that a source
has been telling me that he is actually
on his way out or at very least
now he does currently have a five-year
contract that runs out in April the 23rd
with Paramount to create Star Trek but
that contract was extended to 2026
however it does seem that that contract
is just to create content for his
production company secret hideout and
not necessarily to produce Star Trek so
it might be that Alex kurtzman isn't
necessarily getting sacked as much as
just being removed from Star Trek but
why might that be well it might be
because Paramount is about to sell the
Star Trek franchising one way or another
to a competitor because it desperately
needs money now if you are actually a
Star Trek fan you'll kind of know the
Paramount has always been in financial
stuck and in recent years CBS Powermate
has been in a crapload of debt don't
forget to like subscribe and share the
video with all of your other Gator
friends also you go to side
hashtrack.com for brilliant Stargate
related merged just like this you can
even buy socks and anything else you
want and don't forget the Sidetrack
sides Channel where I do loads of little
live videos and other fun stuff all the
links are in the description currently
that debt stands at 16.4 billion now
that has actually been a reduction it
did touch 20 billion not that long ago
and the credit rating firm um Fitch
recently rated Paramount is a BB Plus
which basically means it's stable but
not necessarily the best place to invest
your money another thing is the rollout
of Paramount plus worldwide has been a
reasonable failure to be honest it
doesn't have anything like the numbers
of Netflix Disney plus HBO Max the
numbers in Europe were sort of like
falsely inflated because they actually
gave Paramount plus away as part of
other packages for example here in the
UK I get Paramount Plus for free because
I have Sky Cinema similar other deals
were done but that means that basically
Paramount weren't really getting a great
deal of income from those subscriptions
so in this case even the subscribers
they've got weren't necessarily paying
their way but another possibly bigger
hint that Star Trek is going to be sold
is the fact that we don't really know
what's happening with Star Trek Beyond
this year
strangely World Series 2 is on its way
Strange New World season 2 is in the bag
it's on its way but we have no news
about series 3.
Picard season three is going to be the
final one and rumors persist the
discovery season 5 will also be the
final one but at very least we don't
have any news again of a season six yet
the same really goes for Prodigy and for
lower decks we don't actually know
what's going on with those Seasons
beyond what we currently have there was
also loads of rumors about other Star
Trek series that kurtzman was going to
produce including like section 31 with
Michelle yo potentially a seven of nine
series aboard the Titan perhaps again
none of these things have been announced
and at the moment they're just rumor
so what is going on is Star Trek about
to get a massive reset it does seem at
least possible
now would it be completely crazy for
Paramount to do something completely
mental like selling Star Trek to say
Netflix
now they wouldn't necessarily have to
sell the ip2 Netflix Lock Stock they
wouldn't have to say like look it's Star
Trek's yours now crack on with it but
what they could do is sell the license
this is really similar to what they've
already done I mean Picard series one
and two here were available on Amazon
Amazon had the international rights and
they've paid for those rights the same
goes for lower decks strange new worlds
was on Paramount plus but Discovery was
always on Netflix even though these
shows all appeared on CBS all action in
the states the rest of the world knows
these shows on very different streaming
platforms
there is one option the Paramount could
just do that but a bit more heavily and
just basically give the production
rights to a company like Netflix that
could produce these TV shows for
Paramount and pay Paramount a license
fee now there have been lots of reasons
why they've not necessarily been able to
do that in the last few years a big
problem being that CBS and Paramount
separated for a while there was
licensing issues there and then when the
companies came back together a lot of
those contracts still existed it all
gets very complicated my sources
explained it to me more than once and I
still don't really get it but that is an
option for Paramount to create a revenue
stream the problem is Paramount doesn't
necessarily need a revenue stream
Paramount needs cash but if it were to
sell one of its biggest franchises to a
competitor does that really then
underline that Paramount plus is a
streaming service is dead well I've been
saying for a long time we have too many
streaming services I mean you can count
those like we're going to have MGM Plus
in January we've got parama plus Disney
plus Netflix
um HBO Max in America America have got
loads of other ones and we then have
Amazon Prime and the list goes on and on
I've always said for a long time it's
too many streaming services people are
not going to pay five six seven lots of
10 pound for their streaming they're
going to end up wanting to only have
maybe two maybe three at a push so that
means some of these streaming service is
at some point going to have to merge now
I would have argued that actually
Paramount should have done this a couple
of years ago instead of creating
Paramount plus out of CBS all access
they should have struck up a deal with
somebody like Netflix they should have
said how about we merge look you need
content we've got some of the most
amazing IP ever we you know we are one
of the big five
um Studios we have movies going back
nearly 100 years
Netflix would have been like yes please
I thank you and they could have then
used the platform of Netflix Netflix
Paramount to create really a super
streaming service a bit like what Disney
did with Fox when Disney bought Fox for
all those billions it was with the
digital media in mind they always had
this idea that Disney on its own as a
streamer platform was weak and I I had
Disney Plus in the first year I barely
watched it but as soon as all the fox
stuff came on damn that became a good
streaming service
full of content full of lots of
different types of content Netflix
empowerment could have struck a similar
deal not necessarily merging the
companies as a whole but merging the
Digital streaming platforms it has to
happen at some point and I honestly
think it will we cannot sustain this
many streaming services and they know it
Netflix lost subscribers and is in
massive debt
Disney plus loses anything up to 500
million dollars a quarter at the moment
for the Disney Network it really is
being propped up by other parts of the
Disney Services now I gotta say though
that was always part of the plan with
Disney they want to compete with Netflix
and the only way to do that is to throw
gobloads and winning at it and Disney
have always planned for that but they
also planned for Disney plus to turn a
profit in 2023 and thanks to the living
crisis and people turning off
subscriptions that doesn't look like
that's going to happen you could also
argue that really other than top gun
Maverick Paramount hasn't really done
anything that's had a massive success
and let's be honest Star Trek 4 was
supposed to be coming out but isn't it's
all begun on hold there's lots of live
Star Trek events that have been canceled
so what do I think
I think Paramount as a company is
reasonably stable
um top gun Maverick was a big success
made a lot of Revenue and continues to
make a lot of Revenue there is a legal
case that's going on that is not great
the way that goes might actually have a
quite a big impact there are rumors that
companies like Paramount and Disney lost
an awful lot of money on the recent
um cryptocurrency Fiasco I don't know if
that's true again but if it is it also
might explain a lot of these problems
all of the streaming services are
struggling so
and as I said there has to be this
merger of streaming services at some
point could Paramount plus be the first
big one to go
if I had to put money on it I wouldn't
bet big and I would say that if
Paramount are in trouble they will try
to sell major assets or have deals to
shift the cost of major assets onto
other streaming services first
and let's be honest they've already been
doing that so could they sell Star Trek
to a major competitor for example
Netflix
yeah would it be good for Star Trek if
they did that
probably
the chances are that if they did sell
the ip2 another streaming service
they're going to want to do a big reset
on what's been going on they might want
to keep the best for example like
strange new worlds but they would
probably almost certainly want to dump
the rest and
what that means for the future could
mean a new Fresh
better Star Trek
I wouldn't mind that but what do you
think get in the comments if you're new
to the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and if you really want to support
the channel and become a fully fledged
side Trekker consider hitting the join
Button as always guys please stay safe
and I'll see you next time
[Music]